it's ever happened where he faked
flights being canceled out of Newark I
think he felt the pressure I think he
knew I had something up my sleeve so
here with a brand new minute
[Music]
holy [__]
I made it
does anyone have any cocaine for me
right now
I had a bunch but I lost it all at the
White House
[Applause]
hope you guys had a great Fourth of July
or I'd like to call it Juneteenth for
white people
let's go invade Iraq again
yeah
let's go to Vietnam best out of three
[Applause]
I used to think I was trans but I'm
nothing into women's sports or drag for
children so
[Applause]
these trans people are doing the Lord's
work they're educating our children and
humiliating our women
[Applause]
because sometimes these [__] have to
be reminded
you're not that good at pickleball
don't make me put on a dress and prove
it to you
[Applause]
[Music]
look at you buddy
here I was ready to have you go against
one of your hardest challenges next week
and then you come in you speed in
obviously you called Yoni ahead of time
you wanted to make it you warned them
this is absolutely incredible and you
come in without a doubt you and cam
Patterson the two resident regulars with
the sets of the night showing how it's
done and it should be much harder for
you two guys than everybody else since
you have to do this every single week
everybody else should be doing their
best minute they should be crushing the
whole way through you come in and you
show exactly how it's done topical stuff
real jokes how do you feel right now I
feel great Tony I was just in seat 12b
tell us about it tell us about the
delays and the travels I tried to update
the audience I said that you were lying
to me at one point I forgot to tell you
guys this at one point he sent me a
picture from uh the customer service
line he goes this is how long customer
service is right now at the airport it
was like a kinda long line I go that's
not even that long of a line and then I
remembered I'm not kidding you by the
way
and then I remembered I have Hans Kim's
location on my phone and something in my
gut was telling me he gave it to me a
long time ago so that I could yell at
him when he does bad open mics and
sometimes I'll see him in a bad Open Mic
I go what the [__] are you good anyway
so I checked his location he's at the
[__] Hilton and then I go did you
just Google a picture of an airport line
and send it to me
I swear to God this is our dialogue I
could have been dealing with anything on
a nice Sunday off and there I am going
Hans make it to the [__] show tell us
more tell us about these fake delays the
very real delays uh [__]
it's all over the news it's on Wall
Street journal.com
very tricky to get over here they
canceled all the flights for a
thunderstorm that never happened these
[__] [__]
I know you told me there was serious
thunderstorms coming in I looked at the
weather report it was like a 40 chance
I'm like what the [__] this is the
weirdest [__] liar man I felt like I
felt like you were in the room with your
girl am I right no you she didn't go on
this trip with you no she did it oh
normally you take the lady on the road
with you Don Barris let me smell his
dick I'll see you yeah
let's find out once and for all
your little
it's not a word no no
no that it only works with a spit in the
mouth thing you can't just start your
own time
I feel like I'm back in the Korean War
absolutely
so uh you you didn't have your girl with
you on this trip no I was all alone all
alone in the Extended Stay uh
I went at 6am for the flight didn't
happen then I went back home and uh to
the hotel just relaxed and I went the
next day today went for the 1 30 flight
that was booked I was on the standby
list so I got bumped to the 330. that
was delayed till 5 30 but I got on and
now I'm here at the greatest live
podcast of the world would have missed
it for the world
Tony yes don't say we have the whole
audience just beat the [__] out of him
for lying
so let me ask you this because normally
you've been taking your girlfriend on
the road with you why did she not end up
on the road with you this weekend where
were you again New Brunswick New
Brunswick New Jersey and you went solo
yeah why did she not go with you this
week uh she didn't go with me this week
because her friend Sophia or I should
have said her name but uh
her friend was in from London England uh
for the Fourth of July so she had to
hang out with her all weekend instead of
coming with me and she went out all
night uh Sixth Street got drunk had a
great time so I'm glad that she's she
has freedom to do that what did it feel
like what did it feel like being alone
on the road were you lonely at all yeah
I was constantly checking her look I
have her look how lonely were you
exactly I was about uh seven
remix
[Music]
it's from Team America World Police that
is the leader of North Korea
okay that's enough
hahaha
that's pretty that's pretty brownry yeah
so what did you do to pass the time uh I
had the kleenex next to my bed the uh
that's all it takes hotels never they
put it in the bathroom I move it to the
bed all the time yeah they don't put
lotions on it hotel rooms though did you
have to use conditioner it [__] sucks
the old spitting conditioner once you
just use the sheets
I was I was at an extended stay so I
yeah and plus Asians uh don't [__] with
their laundry like that you know what I
mean they're known for cleaning the
sheets not dirtying them soil in them
they put the soy in soil all right okay
Hans Kim tell us something interesting
about this week or weekend I recently uh
realized that I might be peeing on my
girlfriend a little bit tell us about
that immediately
because after we have sex we're just
completely naked and then I go to the
bathroom and then there's a little
dribble and then I go cuddle her and
then I feel like she can tell that my
dick is wet and she's right she gets a
little bit of that PF Chang on her
[Music]
that's so stupid this is the dumbest
show ever in the history I don't know
why anybody watches this or is loyal to
us whatsoever it's incredible
um so man how long had you think you've
been slightly peeing on um on your
girlfriend pretty much every night wow
[Applause]
[Music]
little R Kelly reference for the great
Hans Kim very interesting Hans I was
ready if you weren't gonna make it to
have you challenge your spot next week
and like I've said that will always be
on the table if you have a rough set you
are going to be challenged for your spot
I find it to be very very entertaining
and I find it most importantly
to be an incredible way to bring out the
best in you I truly think some of the
best sets that we've seen from you uh in
the past year have been in the past
month or two since I've really lit a
fire under your walk you know what I
mean
and I'm gonna keep it that way and I was
so ready to have you challenged next
week but God damn it you [__] rushed
to be here and then you came up guns
ablazon with one of the best sets of the
night so you have to still do good next
week
but you're not gonna have to challenge
for your spot we're gonna let you happen
thank you Tony
[Applause]
how about one more time for the great
hunts Pam everything
[Applause]
[Music]
well now now now ladies